im letzten monat haben die
kampfhandlungen in syrien um zwei
drittel abgenommen
die opferzahlen sind deutlich gesunken
als hauptsächliche erklärung dafür
werden die deeskalation zogen angeführt
die hier etabliert wurden aber was kann
man sich darunter vorstellen was können
sie wirklich bewirken
[Musik]
russland hat bereits 2015 in syrien
militärisch die initiative ergriffen und
auf seiten als sich an den kämpfen
beteiligt es ist dann auch politisch
sehr initiativ geworden was dazu geführt
hat dass heuer im mai in der hauptstadt
kasachstan in astana ein memorandum
unterzeichnet wurde gemeinsam mit der
türkei und dem iran wo es um die
einrichtung dieser vier deeskalation
szenen ging der westen und auch die
vereinten nationen haben dabei keine
besondere rolle sie sind nur beobachter
was sind nun diese deeskalation szenen
wie sie funktionieren im grunde genommen
geht es um drei wichtige aspekte punkt 1
einstellen der kampfhandlungen inklusive
der luftschläge in diesen gebieten punkt
2 zugang für humanitäre hilfe wahnsinnig
entscheidend in diesem kriegszerstörten
land und drittens aufbau von
infrastrukturen vor an strom und wasser
damit man hier die voraussetzungen
schafft für die rückkehr von
flüchtlingen wichtiger zusatz der kampf
gegen die dschihadistische gruppen
islamischer staat und scharlatan uster
wird nicht eingestellt allerdings die
usa dürfen über diesen zonen keine
luftangriffe mehr fliegen zwei
zusätzliche hinweise an dieser stelle
es ist nicht das gesamte syrien in
diesen zonen erfassungen nur ein kleiner
teil aber der entscheidende teil im
westen und zweitens die zonen sind keine
sicherheitszonen das heißt die garantie
mächte türkei iran und russland wollen
lediglich die überwachung hier in diesen
bereichen sicherstellen aber sicher
nicht den schutz der gesamten
bevölkerung in diesen gebieten
betrachtet man die vier zonen im
gesamten fällt auf dass sich zwei zonen
in grenznähe befinden im norden und im
süden und zwei zonen im landesinneren
insofern von bedeutung weil
das immerhin die rebellen auf sich
alleine gestellt sind an den rändern
können sie unterstützung von außen
erhalten
von norden nach süden betrachtet erste
zone ii blieb sehr schwierig weil dort
noch heftige kämpfe zwischen den
einzelnen rebellengruppen herrschen
russland und die türkei wollen hier für
ordnung sorgen zweite zone
das ist nördlich von homs ein kleines
gebiet aber verkehrstechnisch sehr
wichtig das ist ein schnitt punkt das
ist eine schnittstelle im lande selbst
und ganz bedeutend auch das hier
iranische schiitische milizen sich
zurückgezogen haben und hier ihre basis
gefunden haben dann haben wir die dritte
zone das ist österreich folgen der
hauptstadt damaskus ist gut da wie das
heißt sehr wichtig weil von dort die
wasserversorgung sichergestellt wird
dass auch in rebellen hochburg
und hier wird der kampf gegen die
dschihadistische elemente geduldet und
weitergeführt
im süden im raum dar und kulterer haben
wir die grenze zu israel und jordanien
und diese beiden staaten hätten gerne
dass die usa hier eine besondere rolle
spielen allerdings vor ort sind syrische
kräfte und russische kräfte
wo stehen wir derzeit wie schaut die
sache aus drei der vier zonen sind
eingerichtet anscheinend an los zu
funktionieren die opferzahlen sind
gesunken die kampfhandlungen haben
nachgelassen der zugang für die
humanitäre hilfe ist ermöglicht eine
zone ist problematisch so dass es die
zone im norden blieb weil eben hier so
heterogene gruppen agieren 2011 haben
sich mittlerweile den vereinbarungen
angeschlossen 230 bewaffnete
gruppierungen haben die waffen
niedergelegt daher sind auch die
kampfhandlungen gesunken
man könnte kurzem sagen die zonen
funktionieren wie kann es daher
weitergehen was wären die nächsten
schritte russland türkei und iran selber
bezeichnen dass der zeg deeskalation
szenario nur als einen zwischenschritt
als militär strategische maßnahme die in
weiterer folge zu frieden führen soll
sie möchten sie her die zonen aus denen
auf ganz syrien wenn es soweit
funktioniert von außen betrachtet ist
das bild ein bisschen ambivalent
zweifellos ist festzustellen dass hier
die kampfhandlungen reduziert wurden die
opferzahlen gesenkt wurden die
humanitäre hilfe ermöglichen
wird und somit das leiden vieler syrer
gelingt oder vielleicht sogar beendet
wird auf einen zweiten blick muss man
feststellen dass die politischen
ursachen des konfliktes keinesfalls
gelöst werden man muss auch feststellen
dass hier die souveränität des landes
sicher nicht in zukunft erhalten ist wir
haben zwar die grenzen aber wir haben
den massiven einfluss dieser drei
genannten staaten
und drittens ist anzuführen dass der
kampf gegen den as und dessen
unabsehbare folgen ja noch nicht zu ende
ist daher hier wirklich ein etwas
kritischere spielt fazit allerdings nach
sieben jahren bürgerkrieg gibt es hier
wirklich erste positive anzeichen die
hier eine klare verbesserung für einen
teil der bevölkerung bringen
eine wirkliche frieden chance sehe ich
allerdings nur dann wenn die vereinten
nationen eine führende rolle übernehmen
und syrien nicht vollends zum geo
politischen spielball wird
[Musik]